[Musik]
hallo erfahren so verlief wie heute gibt
es ein superschnelles rezept und zwar
machen wir spaghetti alla carbonara
aller sally aller murat da ist der titel
länger als rezept an sich und wir
brauchen auch noch ganz wenige zutaten
ursprüngliche und traditionell
italienisch verträgliches nudelgericht
aus schinken und käse wir machen heute
allerdings nicht mit schenken da wird es
nicht essen
das heißt wir tauschen die flut aus aber
ich bleibe ich jetzt erstmal die zutaten
dafür brauche ich für 100 gramm nudeln
ich habe 200 gramm pasta mal das 140
liter sahne frische eier etwas basilikum
etwas muskatnuss und pfeffer und
frischem parmesan da nämlich etwa finden
sich fische parmesan eben sein kann
minute gereist aber damit meinen
fahrbahn am stück das rezept geht auch
super schnell das heißt als erstes muss
jetzt zuerst einmal machte aufkochen
lassen
das ist schon mal der wichtigste partner
und mit salz ein gleiten und kaufte
wasser kochen das ja kochen das
nudelwasser ganz leicht kochen macht es
allemal presse hier über die frage unter
den videos kommt wo bekomme ich kochen
des nudelwasser ganz klar logisch denn
auch mit dem polster und jetzt nehme ich
den fachfirma und zwar oder und zwar ist
das türkische kinder schenken und er hat
von der romand mit frankes also türkisch
und das ist so eine art design
aufschrift es gibt auch als
brotaufstrich und es schmeckt natürlich
super lecker nachrichten wird nach
knoblauch auch noch nachts beitragen
aber das ist nicht schlimm und unsere
lieblings mag ist dass das hier ist eine
meiner auf schmeckt echt super songs wie
sweet wanjura und es gibt in jedem
möglichen supermarkt dabei bei unserem
kloster jetzt weiter riecht noch nicht
aber heute wo alles hier immer bei uns
im ort
[Musik]
gewürfelt
der vorteil daran ist ich muss nichts
anbraten also markant anbraten aber ich
muss nicht schmeckt auch so schon
richtig gut anbraten
die würzige frau spricht von hier drauf
meine wasser braucht das heißt kann
jetzt kinosaals reingeben dann die noten
und damit gleich über kopf von flexi
kopflos raus
manche leute sprechen ja die spaghetti
ich wirklich will lieber so rein
das tut auch schön fand einfach keine
spaghetti hohen wir kochen nach
packungsanleitung bei mir sind es etwa
acht minuten und ich könnte ihnen
dazwischen zeit schon mal weitermachen
und zwar werden die eier jetzt früher
verwendet aber dadurch dass später die
halfen nudeln löffel kommt schmeckt auch
gar nicht nur noch ein
mit pfeffer und muskat wirkung da noch
gemeinsam mit rein und wen sie am besten
macht frisch gerieben bin einfach keine
brennstoffe mit drin und lasst uns
einfach drei oder vier küche ist neben
register ziehen
wir waren übrigens auf
du hast noch vier minuten
und jetzt kann ich auch schon mal
basilikum fein hacken
kommt diese sogleich an die meinungen
aufeinander übereinander
sie soll auch so ein cooles feierabend
gewicht also wenn ihr nach der arbeit
machen und bekommt einfach nur kurz vor
katy abkochen
es dauert am längsten interesse ist also
vorbereitet hier besteht zutaten hier
rein
und auch die sahne frage wie kann die
sahen ihr habt ja auch nicht reinmachen
einfachen gesetz mit dabei ok also wenn
keine sahne butter oder ungarn schlug
will aston martin dbs
diese umwandlung die man da hatte man
autos um das fest am später wie sondern
rot geführt um die notwendig und jetzt
freu mich ja auch dass die nudeln
so sieht's aus
letztere unserer ablesen und manche
frage ich sie bekomme ich denn die
kostüme weg ohne mich zu verbrennen und
zwar ist es ein modernes land einfach
weg oder hoch mal runter und dann
natürlich mit dampf hier hoch und man
verbrennt das heißt richtig macht man so
dringend moratti hat auch nicht
verschlafen
jetzt nämlich so heiß sind und geht
direkt mit wasser jetzt schnell durch
früher richtig tolle weniger wasser und
ganz ganz wichtig ist natürlich all den
gewinn
wir halten an meine mama so lange macht
jetzt nochmal getötet
minute reingeschrieben holen wir uns
hier raus meine mama war das egal
[Musik]
sozusagen das essen schmeckt zu mir und
allah auch richtig gut
[Musik]
es ist ungelogen ich glaube du hast es
gebe ich mich in zehn minuten gemacht
werden brauchen ja nur 8 minuten ein
großer teller
genau wie die typische pastell riesig
aus ins klein aus
das kann man nicht aufheben sollte man
am besten gleich egal
[Musik]
dass wir ganz einfach verschwendet alles
über 1 hatte der rheinländer
dabei kannst du die presse so schön
[Musik]
anschaulich und vor allem ist
superschnell sehr lecker gerne und falls
ihr die sofort nachmachen volt und auch
auf den geschmack kommen seit und luft
bekommen würde ich wäre wirklich so
mersch aus tennis - block b ist vorbei
dass wir das noch mal ganz genau ich mir
einen sprachlehrer aber egal und
moralische natürlich wie es jetzt auf
und ich wünsche euch allen auch im
nächsten maschine habe ich mich
gestorben oder typische charakteristika
auch an meine freunde
[Musik]
geblieben
begrüßen
[Musik]